time uh on the Boston side back to them
15 and4 tied for the best record in the
NBA with the Minnesota
Timberwolves um at who Tu 15 I'm not I'm
still not sold on Timberwolves that's
just my personal opinion but I will say
this but how sold are you on the Boston
Celtic Celtics gonna win a
championship Celtic Boston Celtics are
the best team in the NBA is that is that
calling for
a is that calling for calling for a post
it yes all right guarantee it all right
the Boston Celtics are going to win the
championship
gante there it is what's the date today
guarantee day 12 guante what is this
124 oh my how did y'all know thank you
thank you what's the DAT today this the
fifth or the fourth I love it December
4th Celtics will win the championship
says the chuckster Ernie I will say one
thing to makes me nervous what the
porzingis is hurt yeah left calf I
like he got to be healthy but I'm still
going with the Celtics I think the
additions of Drew holiday to go with
those two guys and and porzingis if he
can stay healthy and how and how
dominant does porzingis have to be he
don't have to be but he's the fourth
best player on the team he does not have
to be dominant he just has to be the
best number four in the NBA right now
he's giving him 19 and seven a night
that's pretty good and and no number
four is going to do that and uh Drew
holiday meantime um not doing much you
know
defensively he's he's awesome
offensively it's been a a down year so
far for Drew holl that's not his role
aren't he I know I know but I'm just
saying career low field goal
percentage but you think about and his
assist numbers but you're playing with
Jaylen you playing with Jaylen Brown
Tatum porzingis who's averaging
19 he might not shouldn't the assist
numbers be up so not necessar one one
players those guys are one-on-one
players they're not the kind of guys
that's going to run and you can get fast
breaks and D they are great one they're
great one-on-one players so his his not
but Ashley the biggest thing he's GNA do
go ahead we got to do an interview very
nice